tu viens nous voir non seulement pour le
spectacle qui passe vendredi sur ces 8
mais aussi pour un nouveau projet
puisque tu te lances dans le fromage
ouais tout le monde me faisais la blague
il varie toutefois la blache chantal tu
manges du cantal et a décidé de te
lancer notre hommage exactement le
cantal là dessous avec mes chers est
assez fine gueule et on y vient bien
manger hommage à découvert un fromage
dans l'or puisque je fais polonaise cgem
le petit hollandaises belges jouent donc
réduire un gars qui est près de
maroilles d'accord mais ça j'aime
beaucoup le marouane et on a décidé
comme ça s'efface lors d'un dîner mais
pourquoi vous 3 deripaska et michel si
amy et moi aussi on met la main dans sa
pub cantal la to save gimone fromagerie
et c'est une appellation d'origine
protégée d'accord alors est ce qu'on
peut en avoir parce que tu nous en a
ramené tout nous a fait l'honneur de
ramener un tollé et les téléspectateurs
on va le goûter et voilà public alors
bien entendu bien il ya les gestes
barrières non merci merci merci
dans l'odeur allez-y vous pouvez prendre
un petit morceau chez vous ça oui ça
revient de chez elle alors moi j'aime
bien non malheureusement non
alors c'est le cantal la douce et le
fromage que chantal ladesou alors est ce
que vous en pensez et fouette un bas
voilà donc chantal c'est son fromage le
cantal à tout ça vous plaît mais on
dirait que de l'anchois dessus ah non
non je crois pas je suis non non non à
celle que tu as fait un donc moi je
n'aime pas ça excusez moi mais je suis
pas dans le fromage que vous en pensez
quoi vous aimez alors moi je vais
malheureusement je je je respecte
chantal rouquet en tout cas ils sont
bons gars il est bon mais oui mais voilà
cantal là-dessus ciel comme un cochon
cas merci chantal vous reste avec nous
avant d'agresser on t'aime on te
retrouve vendredi soir sur cevital et
les 'sherpas' à la dernière partie je
touche pas
c'est la vie actuellement bon ya bien
sûr c'est une connerie et personne ne
soit pas là dessus et ag2r choix et mes
mots et vous avez dit qu'il était très
bon quel mytho suis là pour moi j'avais
un vrai fromage